había anunciado su pretensión de llegar
a la neutralidad de carbono para el año
2050 también recordemos que llegó a la
casa blanca con la promesa firme de no
permitir nuevas perforaciones de
petróleo y gas en terrenos federales en
este contexto y teniendo esto en cuenta
cómo explica esta medida Entonces qué es
lo que la motiva para usted
bueno es una contradicción Total no en
términos de de La retórica que viene
dando la administración de de por un
lado nos está diciendo que quiere que
quiere tratar de solucionar la crisis
climática que estamos viviendo y por el
otro está autorizando este proyecto que
es un un proyecto masivo y que no
solamente se detiene en lo que es el
proyecto que se ha propuesto pero que la
compañía misma con ecops que está detrás
de este proyecto ha dicho que lo que
quieren hacer es que este proyecto sea
la base la fundación de expandir
todo todo el petróleo que quieren sacar
del Ártico Norte Entonces estamos
hablando de doscientos millones 270
millones de toneladas de gases de efecto
invernadero
más más aparte estamos viendo que que
quieren sacar creo que seis mil
seiscientos millones de barriles de
petróleo y aparte de eso arriba de todo
esto
se está diciendo que también quieren
tener acerca de mil millones de barriles
de petróleo para extraer en en el área
que rodea el proyecto que ya
que ya han recibido la aprobación
cuéntenos Raúl que dice las
legislaciones estadounidense sobre este
tipo de proyectos que tienen como usted
bien describe este tipo de impactos en
el medio ambiente que requieren
bueno el presidente tiene toda la
discreción de tomar la decisión de de
aprobar o no este este proyecto lo que
no lo que el presidente no puede hacer
es fallar en el proceso de esa
aprobación Y esto es lo que estamos
viendo Durante este proceso la ley
requiere que el presidente analice las
las consecuencias particularmente
aquellas ambientales y y aquellas que
tengan que ver con el cambio climático
y y que las tome en cuenta de una manera
seria mientras tome esta decisión cuando
esta misma decisión fue tomada en la
administración de Trump a nosotros con
muchos de nuestros compañeros
ambientalistas a la la peleamos en corte
y y identificamos miles de fallas a que
ellos tuvieron acerca del proceso lo que
estamos viendo acerca de de esta misma
decisión que la administración de vaina
ha tenido es que no se han curado esas
fallas que que tomó el presidente Trump
y no soy y y que nosotros hemos visto en
el mismo récord de la administración de
biden Entonces tenemos que analizar el
caso Pero si esas fallas continúan vamos
a tener que pelearlo en corte de nuevo
cuéntenos concretamente Qué impactos
Podría tener a nivel medioambiental
porque no estamos hablando de cualquier
región Tiene ciertas particularidades
Sí exactamente O sea la región es es muy
compleja y aparte tiene muchos muchos
recursos naturales en términos de
petróleo las 270 millones de toneladas
que de gases que se pondrían sería el
equivalente Añadir dos dos millones de
coches
en nuestras carreteras por los
siguientes 30 años aparte de todo esto
Wilo es el hogar de osos polares de
asientos de miles de aves de aves
migratorias y una de las manadas de
caribú más grandes que quedan en el
norte polar todos es todas estas
especies que son muy importantes no
solamente para conservar en términos
ambientales pero también para para las
creencias espirituales de de tribus que
que viven ahí estarían estarían en en
peligro por esa decisión